Go ahead.
Okay. Is your mic on? Yeah, I'm
getting, this is making me nervous.
Maybe I should get my epipen.
Are you allergic to radio
greatness that I know of.
I haven't been really exposed to it
yet. Anyway, let's go. Are we rolling?
We're good. We're going,
we're rolling. Okay.
I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and today we're going
to begin with a conversation between Dan
Pashman. Okay. Um, post of a podcast
here at w NYC called the Sporkful.
It's about food and Amy Pearl. Amy. Yes.
A digital producer here at
the station who likes food.
And the conversation they had was
about something that happened to Amy,
which she never expected,
certainly didn't want.
And yet it could happen
to any of us at any time.
So years ago, before any
of this happened to you,
just tell me what was your
relationship with meat?
My relationship with meat? Yeah. Well,
you know how when you're
little and your mom is like,
you could have any special
dinner for your birthday.
My dinner was meatballs and
she was like, except me.
Balls are so hard to
make. So it was pot roast.
And then Peter Lucchino, Peter Luger's
mistake house in Brooklyn. Yeah,
I used to go there quite often and I live
there and I have a Peter Liquor credit
card, so all those hard to
get I, you know, I don't,
I don't know how they give them
out, but nobody seems to have one.
I don't think they give them out anymore.
But I mean I was very interrupted.
Like I was living in
Williamsburg and it just,
it opened at like one o'clock every day
and you could just walk in at one that
had an amazing bar. There's
no tablecloths on the table.
These old German waiters, they bring
out your porterhouse for three.
They put a little plate upside down and
then put the big platter on top of it.
So it's tilted and all
the juice runs to the end.
And then they like have the special
double spoon thing that they somehow like
scoop juice onto your
steak and oh, so good.
And also like the smell of burning
fat from a hamburger. What do I mean?
Dogs? Oh my God, I love hotdogs so much.
When you bite into them and they're like,
I'm have like a snap and like having a
weenie roast out in the open air is just
at, it's like the, Oh
God, so good. Anyway, I,
I was always very intimate.
What changed? Oh my God,
it was terrible. It was, what happened
was I was having this beautiful,
it was spring time.
I was having a beautiful leg of lamb with
some neighbors and we'd like put it on
the grill and it was just a
delicious, beautiful dinner.
And I had served with it some ramps that
I foraged in my mom's yard for ramp by
the way, is just a wild onion. And so,
so we had this delicious
meal and then, you know,
I went home and I was going
to sleep at like midnight,
like few hours later and I
just felt weird. I was like,
Oh God, something's wrong.
I feel like really anxious,
like something's wrong with me.
And I went in the bathroom and I like
look in the mirror and my face was like
all weird looking. And I was like,
I kept laying down and be like,
I'll just sleep it off, whatever
it is. But every time I laid down,
I felt like I was going to faint. So I
was like prop myself up and I was like,
Oh God does having terrible like stomach
cramps and just like a weird feeling of
impending doom, you know? But
just like anybody, I'm just like,
just get a good nights
sleep. This'll pass.
I like splash a little water on
my face. I mean, I'm tell him,
made me think this, but I
thought like maybe a snail,
a tiny snail was on one of them ramps
that I ate and it was like poisoning me
somehow, you know, snails, I
mean they probably poisonous.
So I called my friends in the morning.
I was like, hey, how are you guys doing?
How was dinner? They were
like, oh, so great. I was like,
really so great. Nothing
weird like panic attacks.
And they were like, and they were
like, oh, that was so lovely.
Thank you so much. Let's do it again.
Blah, blah, blah. I was like, wow.
I really had a rough night and,
but I didn't think anything of it.
And I went on with my life,
you know, just like whatever.
And then about a week or two later I
made some cheeseburgers and I ate a
cheeseburger and I was
watching 'em goodbye Mr Chips,
really teared jerking movie
and a good book too. And um,
about a couple of hours
after I ate, I was like,
started to feel really weird again.
I was like feeling like I was like,
had to stand up. I was like, I think I'm
gonna Faint. I feel really lightheaded,
I can't catch my breath. I feel like
really woozy. But if anytime I laid down,
I really felt like I was going to faint.
So I was like trying to say sitting
upright and I was like, oh my God,
this is very slim.
Or I've ran into the bathroom and I was
like looking in the mirror and lo and
behold,
I had hives all over my stomach and then
they started coming out in my hands and
I was like, oh my God,
something's happening.
And at one point I did get up and unlock
my door because I did feel like I'm
going to pass out,
call an ambulance and then they're
not going to be able to get in.
So I mean I was in a little bit afraid
of what was happening and when I woke up
in the morning,
the first thing I did was Google sudden
meat allergy cause I was like this seems
like an allergy. And the only
thing that was the same was meat.
And I'm going through and like the second
thing that came up was this article
that was like Florida man has
sudden meat allergy. I was like,
oh my God, I think it's a
possible I could have this.
And so I made an appointment
with my doctor. I brought
in the article, I'm like,
I'm going to be this person, but I can
do it. I had the article in my pocket,
you know,
the person who goes to their doctor
was something I found on the Internet.
So I brought the article,
it was in my pocket and like I got
through the like checkup and I was too
chicken. I went when I was
paying the receptionist,
I pulled it out and gave it to
the receptionist and I was like,
could you give this to the doctor?
So that was like the best I could do.
And then I did call my doctor and had
a conversation with them on the phone
asking him if I could get
tested. And he was like, no,
there's no such thing as a
meat allergy, blah blah blah.
So some people think allergies are
just like in your head and people,
this is science writer, Peter Smith.
We got in touch with him after Lee
heard Amy's story because Peter is an
investigator of many things including
strange allergies and people are like,
mushrooms hurt them or they think wifi
hurts them. Yeah, Wifi hurts them.
And I don't know. And
when our producer left,
if NASA and I got into the studio and
we told them about Amy story, he said,
yeah, all right. I know exactly who
you need to talk to. Hello? Yeah.
Hi Thomas Platts mills. This is Thomas
Plant smells. That's right. How are you?
I'm very well.
Dr [inaudible] Mills is down at the
University of Virginia in Charlottesville.
He's a professor and he works at an
allergy clinic, donut allergy clinic.
We are constantly sifting through
stories, which not only you don't believe,
but are actually nonsense simply. And
he told us in the last 10 years or so,
he started hearing lots of
stories, just like Amy, right?
Somebody shows up at the office,
convinced that they're allergic.
All of a sudden for no
apparent reason to red meat.
The first time I heard it was probably
as early as 2004 and every single time he
heard the story, he would tell the patient
exactly what Amy's doctor told her.
Nope, no way. No, no, no.
It's not possible. Right?
So what was wrong with these
complaints? You know, uh, you know,
in an Orthodox medical way,
oh, everything. Everything.
Adults don't become allergic to something
they've eaten for 40 years out of the
blue and certainly not red meat. So
you're basically saying to these patients,
I think you must be making this
up because I can't explain it.
I don't use language like
that. I said, I say that.
I was saying I was trying to
give you your inner voice. Oh,
you don't want to know what doctors
are thinking in their inner voices.
You know? You often think in
the middle of an interview.
Is it possible that he's got, you know,
some ghastly disease? Mad Cow. Yeah.
You know, the point is that when
he'd hear a story like Amy's,
he just didn't believe it,
but then everything changed.
Thanks. Oddly enough to cancer drug,
this new cancer drug called
Cetuximab in New York. Today,
Martha Stewart was indicted
on criminal charges relating.
This is the very drug that got Martha
Stewart in all that trouble for insider
trading. It. Remember that I went to
jail for six months. Yeah. Anyway,
very promising, exciting
new drug, but then
doctors were giving people this injection
and I would just end up on the floor
of the doctor's office in shock. Yeah.
That would be an NF lactic shock.
Their hearts would start beating faster.
They'd get short of breath
and get stomach cramps.
Their immune system would start to
overreact to something new and alien that
came in with the drug. Basically
a classic allergic reaction.
So the industry lands on Thomas
pots. Mills his desk. Yes.
So we were asked to look at Cetuximab
to see if they could figure out what was
causing the reaction. And He tests
two groups of blood, a control sample,
and then people that have this allergy
and he quickly zeroed in on a particular
molecule. The sugar, it
was part of the drug.
This sugar Galack Toes
Alpha one three gallon toes.
Oh, Alpha Alpha Gal. Yeah,
as in a particularly great lady. Yeah.
Better than the Beta or gamma gallons
like Alpha male Alpha female didn't quite
have a ring to it for
Alpha. The alpha. Anyway,
it seemed like Alpha Gal
was the culprit. Yeah.
And if you'd told me four years earlier
that there's a whole lot of people out
there who are allergic to this sugar,
I'd have thought you were smoking.
You know vaping again,
because not only does this sugar
Alpha Gal show up in the cancer drug,
and this is where we get back to Amy, it
also shows up in the blood of mammals.
[inaudible]
all non primate mammals.
So every time you eat
lamb or beef, goat, camel,
even tripe or pig's kidneys,
you're also eating Alfa Gallo.
[inaudible].
So I'm reading this
article and it says like,
it's this thing called
Alpha lactase or Alpha gala.
So it made no sense that someone like
Amy who'd been eating meat all her life
would suddenly somehow
be allergic. The AlphaGo,
I just was like, this was
so stupid. The whole show.
One day it's getting
to be barbecue season.
I usually have like a couple of barbecues
where I'd just do a whole park bought
and brisket and like hang
out all day doing it.
And I was like very wanted
to do that and I was like,
I'm just going to not eat meat and not
even know. So I was like, forget it.
My doctor all tests me,
I'm gonna test myself.
So I was like going to be very careful.
I got a thing of Benadryl and I was
like, I'm not going to do it alone.
I'll do it with my mom, my poor mom.
And so I went up to my mom's and
she's like really into food too.
So she was like, oh this is so exciting.
I got two porterhouse steaks on Salads,
dues zoos explained to her
what testing he had dead.
Cause I had talked a little bit about it
with their so like fire up the grill do
the porter has,
I even think I like Instagram that as
a joke like ha ha ha this might be the
last time you hear from me.
But so you know we're
having a nice summer day.
Just me and my mom having our steak.
I ate like a couple of bites cause I was
slightly nervous and I was like sitting
in the grass with my dog and reading a
book and trying to think like do I feel
normal? Which try it folks.
It's hard to figure out when you start
asking yourself do I feel normal?
Does this, am I breathing?
Oh it's my stomach hurt or
something wrong. And I was like,
after a while I was like
Ugh, I feel pretty good.
And the neighbor came over and was
like chatting with us and it was in the
middle of that conversation
where I was like, oh,
I kind of feel like I have
to go to the bathroom,
but maybe I just have to go to the
bathroom. So I went to the bathroom.
I was sitting there and I was
like, Oh God, something feels bad.
And then I was like, Oh God, I
definitely, this is not right,
something's wrong.
And I went in to get the Benadryl and I
took the Benadryl and I went on my bed
and at the guestroom at my mom's and I
was like sitting on there and I was like,
oh, I just don't feel right. Oh,
maybe I just take a deep breath.
I'll just stand up. Maybe I just put
my hands over my head like this. Hi.
That does feel slightly better I
think. And then I was finally like,
I think we should go to the hospital.
And I went out side. I was like, mom,
I think you have to
drive me to the hospital.
She was like talking to her
neighbor like, what? Oh my God,
let me go change my
clothes, change my clothes.
I'm like, mom, you know she's not
wearing the hospital level clothes,
so I'm like, okay, hurry up mom, mom,
are you ready mom? And then I was like,
while she was changing your clothes,
I suddenly was like, oh my God,
I got my wallet out and my Cell Phone
and I've like threw it towards my mom's
bedroom door and I was like,
here's my insurance card.
Call an ambulance and I
just like hit the floor.
Eventually the ambulance
arrives and I got stabilized.
I was strapped to the thing.
I was in the emergency room like
they were shooting. They full of,
I don't know what Epinephrin and
adrenaline and the little like 12 year old
mercy room doctor runs in and he was
like, I looked it up on the Internet,
Africa. Fascinating. What? That's
terrible. I've never heard of that.
Could it be true? Yes, it's true. Like
they're all having this discussion there.
Then when I went back to my doctor
after that and I was like, Hey,
just get out of the emergency room,
because they tested me for Alpha gout.
I'm allergic to meat.
So this is an allergy. Yeah.
So all of a sudden you're looking at the
quote crazies and they're not so crazy
anymore. Absolutely.
We suddenly had a blood test and of course
what turned out is all these patients
who'd been telling us this
story were allergic to AlphaGo,
but, but it's still like a mystery. Right?
There are Thomas Platts mills couldn't
figure out why people like Amy,
who had lived for 40 years
eating porterhouse steaks
at Peter Luger's a credit
card. Why would she
suddenly develop an allergy?
Now there's gotta be some
kind of trigger. Yes.
Two we were looking for anything that
could explain it. It could be a mold,
it could be a nematode worm or a fungus.
But then he looked again and noticed
that all the people who had had bad
reactions to the cancer drug, they were
in a particular area of the country
that was Virginia, North Carolina,
southern Missouri, Arkansas.
No cases in Salt Lake
City, no cases in Denver.
Smatterings down the west. So he turned
to his technician, Jake, and he said,
I said,
you've got to Google every map you can
find and say what matches that area,
cures or diseases that appear
where ever the allergy appears.
So Jake starts googling, googling
and googling and googling. Yeah.
And eventually he comes across a map
that matches where the cases are very
beautifully. The maximum area
for rocky mountain spotted fever.
So he made this little map and it's like
the shaded dark areas of the country
are at places with rocky
mountain spotted fever.
And then there's like some stars where
you know this, this allergy hit appeared.
Yeah. And they, they overlap.
Ah, very interesting.
And then all of a sudden it clicks.
Rocky mountain spotted fever
is a tick borne disease.
This is the distribution
of the Lonestar tick.
And actually just a little before this,
it turns out and allergists down
in Australia, Sheryl van Noonan,
first name Cheryl is h Goyo, the Noonan,
v I n and then nun e n and I'm
from the Tikkun juiced. Allergies,
research and awareness
center in Sydney, Australia.
She says she was now being visited by
all kinds of people who claim suddenly to
be allergic to meat. And whenever
I take a history, so for example,
I'd ask them, was there a family
history of rhinitis, Eczema, asthma,
a stinging insect allergy. And they
say they've all been bitten by ticks.
When we started asking patients,
we suddenly heard the
stories just out the Kazoo
[inaudible]
but at this point, Dr Platz
Mills, all he has is a map,
some stories and a hunch, right?
So, so what does he do? He decides,
well maybe I'll just do this
to myself. He does what?
He decides to test it on herself. Oh my
God. He sort of like [inaudible] like
the nihs that he did it intentionally.
I know I had no intention. I mean he,
I think he also likes to walk and
amble and think about things, right?
So he goes for a long walk and
along the Blue Ridge Mountain.
And I knew I wanted to be off trial
because I'm actually rather allergic to
humans. So he's walking
and walking and walking.
And along the way, ah,
he bumps into a whole bunch of texts
and if you walk into a nest of those
things, oh my God, this sounds
like a nightmare. Yeah, absolutely.
I got 200 seat ticks a
boy and then in of that
year I was taken out to dinner and the
lamb chops were particularly delicious
and the French wine was delicious
and six hours later I woke up,
covered in hives.
[inaudible]
he's got an allergy to red meat all
just because of the tick by tick bite.
That's right.
[inaudible] you're right
back after this. Hi,
this is Sarah calling from
Asheville, North Carolina.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
when the legendary rapper prodigy died
after being hospitalized for sickle cell
anemia last year. His friends,
his fans were shocked in a cemetery
like you're talking about this sunny day
right here that we have right now, man
making beats Friday g is dead right now.
I'm Mary Harris and I'm
Christopher Johnson.
The realness is a new
podcast from w NYC studios.
It takes you inside prodigy's music and
asks why he couldn't escape a single
recessive gene.
Listen and subscribe to the realness
wherever you get your podcasts.
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab.
Now we go back to Amy just when she's
discovered that the allergy to meat that
she's developed comes from a tick bite,
a tick bite. Hang on a second.
Because like a few weeks before all
this started happening, as I said,
I was forging for ramps in my mom's
backyard and I had a tick on my,
on my arm.
Now it turns out that not only was that
tick bite a terrible thing for Amy,
it was a kind of double
tragedy from [inaudible]
amongst the trees. I
didn't, the undergrowth,
and I think it's only right at this
point to backup is a fascinating world of
wonders and consider the story
from the tics point of view.
[inaudible]
okay. So, uh, I'm Graham heckling.
I am a wildlife disease ecologist
at the University of Tennessee.
So I was wondering if you could help us,
uh, tell the story of a, in this case,
the lone star tick that
bit Amy. Oh yeah, sure.
So they start off on
this little pile of eggs,
perhaps a massive 2000
eggs under the leaves.
The proud mom who just
gave birth at that point,
she's just a kind of a
withered husk meaning dead.
But anyway, a few weeks later,
those eggs will hatch and this massive
2000 baby techs emerge from under the
leaves. Could I see
them with my naked eye?
If you ran into a mass
of them all up together,
you would feel like you've got a little
smudge of dirt and then the dirt starts
walking.
And so they'll just climb up and they'll
know potentially all be on the same
leaf, all the same looking
for something to feed on. Now,
one teeny little tiny problem for these
teeny little tiny ticks is that they dry
out. So when they come
up from under the leaves,
they come up briefly and then they
go back down, get a little water,
come back up, get thirsty, go back down.
And rehydrate. So they like commute.
Exactly. And we refer to the behavior
as questing Ah, restless thing.
So if you were one of these little baby
ticks questing for food while you're up
there,
you are essentially velcro because on
each one of your little legs you have
little kind of hook like structures.
And so you're flat against the leaf,
sort of sniffing in the air with your two
little front legs I can detect you see
a two heat movement.
So let's say one day you're sitting
there on your leaf and you pick up the
scent, I mean nearby mouse mice of
the potato chips or the ecosystem,
everything he gets them. You might
be about to have the very first meal.
So you basically stand up,
stretch out all your little
legs and do a tick dons.
And so it's kind of interpretive dance
like movements while you're waiting for
that mouse to come just close
enough that you can grab onto it.
So you're dancing and you're waiting and
you're dancing and you're waiting and
you're dancing and you waiting
and you're dancing on your way to,
to be honest,
you are probably going to wait your
entire life and die unfulfilled because
there are 2000 of you starting
off and a stable tick population.
There's only going to be two of
you that survive. Oh my gosh.
So 1,998 little baby ticks are
born and then that's it for them.
But let's say that you're one of
the lucky ones and one sunny day.
There you are hanging
out on your little leaf.
When you detect two incoming mammals,
one is a 40 year old hominid,
the other is her dog.
So you perk up to rest
your legs out, wave,
do the tech docs and say
that you're waving and you're
dancing and you're hoping
and you're waving you.
You're dancing and you're
hoping and you're waving and
you're dancing and you're
hoping and slowly the dog getting closer
and closer and closer and you reach out
with one of your tiny little
little, so you get [inaudible]
grab and eat and survive.
But the reason that tick ended up on me
was I slept in bed with my dog naked.
I mean, she's always naked, but I was
also naked. I mean, that's not gross.
I don't, I mean, does that
sound weird? No, but what,
but how do you know
that's what had happened?
Because I know that like I did a good
tick check on myself and I took a shower
and everything.
And then in the middle of the night I
woke up with the itching sensation and I
went to the bathroom and I
couldn't really see what was on,
like something was on the back of
my arm and was a tick. So it's the
tick is biting in the Amy,
what is it giving Amy that's
gonna make her allergic meat?
[inaudible] I need to stop you
there, Robert. Difficult one. Robert.
I don't know the answer to that. Um,
that's Peter Smith and well we joining
us is Cheryl Vanden in the scientist a
it's all up for speculation. We don't
really know [inaudible] here's the theory.
So normally when you eat a piece of meat,
you put Alpha Gal in your stomach and
your stomach digest it and it's in your
body. It is no big deal.
But the tick cunningly will drill into
you poke and you and inject its saliva.
We'll call that tick spit tick spit into
its victims, straight into its victims,
largest organ, the skin and ticks.
But it has an anti clotting factor,
anesthetic, anti inflammatory
compounds and we think the AlphaGo.
Now Peter says the thing about the
skin is the skin is like this enormous,
it's like surveillance system. It's
always on the lookout for invaders.
So when the Alf Gal comes through
your skin covered by all that bad,
they had tick spit stuff that's going to
really like set off your immune system.
The immune system freaks out like oh
[inaudible] and the Alpha Gal covered now
in bad spirit almost sort of by mistake
gets labeled bad and now it's on the bad
guy. Watch list, so therefore
the next time you eat meat,
the meat comes in and then the body
unleashes wave upon wave upon wave of
chemical attacks to do battle against
this AlphaGo and this reaction gets way
out of hand. You've got so many
antibodies multiplying and multiplying,
multiplying, making you rather in
this case, Amy feel just [inaudible].
Ah,
right. I mean it's very weird. It
sounds like a science fiction movie.
It sounds like the beginning of a
science fiction at least kids book,
let's not go to movie, but
like it's, it's just strange,
which all goes to say that this really
is a kind of double tragedy for Amy and
her tech. Yeah. [inaudible] texting
evolve to bite humans, right?
We're a mistake. Like we
have opposable thumbs.
We're either going to pull them off.
I actually woke my mom up and she
helped get it off. Or if they drop off,
they're going to drop off in a airport
terminal or a Walmart carpark or
somewhere like that. Shag carpet
or shag carpet in doors and,
and the doomed and for us,
well we lose something that historically
anyway is a big part of who we are.
Yeah. Because we, we have, we,
we adapted in the grand evolutionary
scheme of things to like eat flesh to eat
meat. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean I'm actually sitting
here picturing a steak,
but actually the thing,
I mean hot dogs like wrap
ramps around a weenie and ruts.
Yama sounds so good. My mouth's water.
We need linis and ramps. Yeah.
But I am going my allergist
tomorrow cause I did, you know,
I was reading this allergy a lot when
I first got it and I read that for some
people the allergy can fade away.
So I'm going to get a blood test to see
what my blood level of Alpha gala is.
So I'm a little already
hoping for it tomorrow.
I want to be normal again.
Hmm.
That was the end of the Dan
Amy conversation. She was
going to go to the doctor,
get herself tested, find out whatever.
So we asked her back in, okay,
that's fine. You know what happened?
So I actually did get an
appointment with my allergist,
Dr [inaudible] name is Dr Korn.
She's really nice. Um, so I got the plan
when I got the blood draw, whatever.
And a few days later my doctor called me
and she said that my numbers were still
really high and I was like,
well how high are they?
And she was like three and I
was like three, that's not high.
And she's like, they're supposed
to be like one or something.
So they had gone down but
they were still, you know,
many times more than they should be.
So when you left and you
were waiting for the call,
where you waiting with the hope that one
that you would soon be eating a bit of
hotdog? I mean honestly I was hoping,
no, no, no, I don't wish it. You are,
you are the big, the great you,
you now that I was afraid that
she would be like, oh my God,
your numbers are so low. I think
you could probably eat meat.
Let's do a food challenge.
I'd be like, ah.
Cause like that's such a scary
memory. Yeah. I don't, you know,
actually just the other night I was
eating at an Indian place and I was eating
vegetarian but like I felt something and
I pulled it out and in the dim light of
an Indian restaurant, like why are
they all let like that? I was like,
was this bacon ice? And
I suddenly, you know,
like you just get this drop
in your stomach. And I'm like,
what time is it four hours from
now if I, you know, cause it's,
there's something about it being delayed
that makes it so difficult at just as
like, like a suspense movie with,
it's like it could happen in the next
three hours or maybe not. I don't know.
I mean honestly, the only thing that,
the real reason I want to be able to eat
meat is so that I will be prepared to
eat it in case of emergency.
I mean I went on a canoe trip in
the Adirondacks and I was like,
well what happens if I
get to try it out here?
And like what if I have to hunt
but I can't even eat meat out.
I have to on fish, but then when the
lake freezes over, what would I eat?
I can't survive.
Something's wrong with me.
I feel evolutionary lead challenged.
This is what I think about
before I go to bed every night.
Would I be able to survive if I
had just what's on me right now,
upenn underwear, my dog. And so,
yeah, I mean that's a real issue.
It's like it's not a real issue.
Obviously it's never going to
happen and live in Brooklyn, but I,
I do for some reason I always think
like I want to be prepared in case,
but um, yeah, you know,
I don't think I would go back
to eating me necessarily.
Like you are still more,
more frightened than game,
so to speak.
Well also like I wish I
could be a vegetarian for
ethical reasons because it's
not so much just the eating meat,
but just like, you know, the, the,
the factory farming
and that kind of stuff.
So I feel like morally superior
now I can be like, well,
I don't eat red meat. Of course I'm forced
to not eat it. But at the same time,
I would, if I had the, if
I had the willpower, I'd
probably go that way anyway.
And then also I think it's great.
It's like we're all evolving
to be on this planet,
which is getting harder to be on and we
know that meat takes a lot of resources
and like now I don't,
now I'm not doing that.
So like the tic is helping me
evolve into a better human being.
[inaudible]
so one could,
instead of thinking of the tick as
your teeny weeny irritating enemy,
you could think of it as a guiding light,
making the world safer to share
with your fellow earthlings. Yeah.
[inaudible]
so you may have lost your
relationship with meat,
but at least you have
your moral superiority.
Yeah. I mean, hi, I'm superior.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
so huge thanks to Amy Pearl for
telling a story which never stopped,
never stopped being scary and wonderful
and to the fellow who brought her into
the room, Dan Pashman, whose
podcast the Sporkful is, it's,
it's all about food in
every conceivable way.
I key talks about eating it, preparing
it, worrying about it. As you've heard,
getting sick from it, getting
fat from it, whatever.
And you can find his show on
iTunes or stitcher or on the
internet@asporkful.com and this story
was produced by Annie Mcewen and Matt
Kielty with reporting help from
Latif Nasser. See you next time.